j'ai vu en fait un concentré de ma
chronique parce qu'on a un activiste
artistes qui en fait est un maquereau
nist pure réalité mais oui parce qu en
fait faut pas oublier que la macro ni a
publié une loi que la loi pacte dans
laquelle une disposition qui s'appelle
naim and shame qui incite toute personne
qui connaît un compas qui qui a
connaissance d'un comportement de
inappropriée une entreprise à la nommer
publiquement pour la recouvrir de l'ontt
ce qu'a fait cet artiste c'est
l'application des lois pacte à la vie
politique donc c'est un pur macro nist
c'est juste effectivement enfin on peut
l'analyser comme vous le soulignez c'est
le miroir de notre société de la société
d'un responsable politique est un pur
représentant de de la mercredi au
pouvoir c'est à dire irresponsable va
demander bill et est en plus très
arrogant parce que la problématique de
la vie privée quand même et centrale sur
ce sujet quand un candidat mais un
argument de la vie privée comme argument
de campagne
donc ça devient un argument public car
politique il a marqué dans ces tracts de
campagne et dans ses matériaux de
campagne c'était un mari rêver encore
c'est écrit noir sur blanc dans toutes
ses communications et c'est un argument
pour voter pour lui donc en face on a un
activiste qui a une preuve vidéo que
c'est faux il fait le name and shame le
balance temps dira attendait c'est faux
parce que quand un argument privée
devient un argument public politique
comment est-ce qu'on peut argumenter
quand un homme politique dit moi j'ai
telle vision de l'économie vous pouvez
contre argumenter en disant je ne suis
pas d'accord
là pour contre-argumenter comment
fait-on soit on disqualifie le discours
en disant ça n'est pas pertinent soit il
faut aller puiser dans ma vie privée
pour pouvoir contrer un argument qui est
opposée par un un dirigeant politique et
la grande immaturité qui la vision
anglo-saxonne quand même qui disent que
quand on est porte parole le
gouvernement on ne fait pas ça en fait
est que c'est pas plus mal si n'est pas
en responsabilité
[Musique]